fire
so with Marvel having previously
announced that they are making an
Inhumans film I figured it'd be a very
good idea to do a video about the
Inhumans because I think a lot of people
know of them but I don't think very many
people know about the human the Inhumans
in depth and so in order to really kind
of bring them about to a wider range of
people
I figure we would explain the Inhumans
with regards to their role in
relationship to the Kree as well as
their role in relationship to the planet
earth humanity itself along with the
Fantastic Four and other heroes and
villains in the Marvel Universe so the
Inhumans have a very rich and beautiful
publication history in Marvel Comics
despite the fact that they are not one
of the premiere members of Marvel Comics
it is to say they are not on par with
the Fantastic Four or the x-men but
despite this despite the fact that they
are not nearly as popular as others they
are included in quite a few storylines
and they are a group of individuals that
Marvel Comics fans always love to see up
here just because of their unique role
in Marvel Comics the unique way in which
they develop their powers as well as the
interesting societal structure that they
have so the Inhumans first appeared and
Fantastic Four issue number 36 and this
is actually not a full on appearance of
the Inhumans that is to say the group as
is being led by their king Black Bolt
what we actually see here is that a
villain named wizard has reformed a
group called the frightful four and the
frightful four was the Silver Age anti
group to the Fantastic Four when I say
Silver Age I simply mean to say that
this was the era in the 1960s whereby a
lot of characters came about the
Fantastic Four the x-men different
groups like that but the frightful four
at this point consists of the
himself along with Madame Medusa the
Sandman and paste-pot pete also known as
the Trapster now we see that the
frightful four comes into contact with
the Fantastic Four and of course as
usual with this Silver Age of comics the
Fantastic Four come out on top
but the purpose of this comic was not to
really see us watch the fifl four come
into conflict with the Fantastic Four it
was designed to introduce us to Madame
Medusa now in issues number 44 through
47 what we learn is that Madame Medusa
is part of a group called the Inhumans
and at some point prior to issue number
36 of the Fantastic Four
Madame Medusa had suffered from amnesia
she had been in some sort of a plane a
plane crash I think we see that
ultimately she comes into contact and is
being chased by an individual named
Gorgon and the way the Gorgon is
introduced to us in issue number 44 of
the Fantastic Four is that he's a
villain of some kind although we don't
really know what we eventually learned
that with a Madame Medusa having
suffered from amnesia she had gone
missing from the Inhumans and that
Gorgon had been tasked by their leader
Black Bolt to find her and to bring her
back we ultimately see that the Inhumans
come into conflict with the Fantastic
Four but it's really more due to a
mistake of intentions rather than either
one or so the Fantastic Four believing
that be and humans were an actual threat
and it was a group they intended to
destroy now one important thing to take
note here is that during Blackpool's
conflict and his fight with the thing of
the Fantastic Four not only is he able
to physically go toe-to-toe with the
thing but he never talks now this is a
very important part of Black Bolt and
this is actually something that's
explained to us and the backstories with
regards to the creation of the Inhumans
and the introduction of their creation
as well as a backstory of Black Bolt and
four issues number 146 to 152
so the backstory of the Inhumans and
blackbolt is given to us m4 issues
number 156 are 146 to 149 in addition
the story of the Inhumans is expanded on
even further in issues 152 153 and
issues 146 and 147 what we see is an
advanced race sharing earth with a very
primitive race and the advanced race is
constantly on the move due to the fact
of the very primitive race is constantly
tracking them down and trying to kill
them because they do not understand the
more advanced race we eventually see
that a blue skinned alien or a robot of
sorts is perusing the environment
looking for a more advanced race and
when it discovers the advanced race it
immediately heads to its home in order
to interact with the species we find out
over the course of issues 146 and 147
that this alien is designed to see how
far this race has progressed even
further we learned that its creators the
Kree were the ones responsible for
creating the Inhumans now we don't learn
what the motivations behind the Kree
were in creating the Inhumans and so
much later but what we do know is that
they had been created by selecting a
small number of humans who at the time
were very very primitive meaning that we
were evolving from Neanderthals to
cro-magnons they had sped up the
evolutionary process of the mental
capacity of humans but had kept humans
the same physiologically meaning that
our minds were more knowledgeable but
our body chemistry and our body
structure remain the same over time the
Kree eventually left although we do not
know why however the Inhumans themselves
continued as a progression of their
species in addition we also see that
their leader at the time I believe it
was rad knack although I'm not going to
swear to that name had undergone a
process called terrigenesis whereby he
had subjected himself to exposure to the
Terrigen myths which granted him
superpowers in addition he goes
undergoes
process of having all of his people
subject themselves to the same process
and we begin to see this sort of cast
for the sort of societal structure form
as a result of individuals who have
undergone this now in Thor issues a
number 148 and 149 were given the
backstory of their leader Black Bolt and
what we learn is that Black Bolt as an
infant had demonstrated the ability to
harness and control electrons and to use
these electrons for virtually any feat
to either create things out of thin air
or to use them as a means to project
energy in addition we also learned why
it is that Black Bolt does not talk and
the reason is because his voice really
kind of resonates on a quasi sonic level
and what we see is that as an infant he
cries and because he cries he creates
this wildly destructive blast of energy
that destroys the entire laboratory in
all most levels the city as a result he
is discovered but he is undergone or put
through the process of learning how to
control his powers and to understand
that he can never talk now in issue
number 149 of Thor we see that he is
kind of reintroduced into in human
society as an adult however his brother
Maximus the mad who will consistently be
someone that will attempt to usurp the
throne of Cain from Black Bolt
will try to get him to talk and
therefore demonstrate that he is not
prepared for the throne and for the role
of King in human society ultimately
Maximus the mad fails and blackballed
along with the his cousin's the inhuman
royal family are able to not necessarily
destroy Maximus but at the very least
thwart his schemes and to allow Black
Bolt to eventually once his parents are
dead
undertake the role of king of the
Inhumans
so following their appearance and for
volume one issues number 146 to 152 we
see that the Inhumans appear an amazing
adventure volume two issues one through
ten
now issues one through eight of amazing
adventure or split books meaning that
the first half of the book focuses on
the Inhumans and the second half focuses
on Black Widow now we see that by issues
nine and ten black widow has been
dropped and those issues focus only on
the Inhumans and during this run of the
Inhumans an amazing adventure what we
see is an attempt yet again by Maximus
the mad to usurp the throne of King from
Black Bolt but we also see that Black
Bolt has his memories wiped so to speak
or his mind wiped by Maximus the mad
then as a result he doesn't quite know
who he is and we see him over the course
of these comics come into contact with
several individuals we see him come into
contact with Thor of the Avengers we see
him come into contact with magneto now
at the end of this run he ultimately
regains his former self and returns as
king to Black Bolt or I'm sorry as king
to the Inhumans in addition by 1975 the
Inhumans are given their own solo run
now this runs until about 2003 over four
volumes but we never really see these
volumes evolve and anything more than
about a 12 issue run and in fact I think
volume 3 might actually be around four
or five issues and what we see over the
course of these volumes is that in
volume 1 again Maximus the mad attempts
to usurp the throne from Black Bolt but
we see that Maximus the mad at the at
the end of volume 1 is a mentally locked
away and volume 2 which many consider to
be the greatest volume of the Inhumans
and perhaps one of the greatest stories
ever told in Marvel Comics is a plot
that has been hatched by Black Bolt to
get his people moved get the Inhumans
moved from the planet earth to the blue
side oxygen-rich part of the Moon in
volume 3 we get a little more backstory
here and what we see is running the
accuser who is the current ruler of the
Kree Empire
appearing to the inhumans with the
intention of putting them back in there
in their role with regards to the Cree
and what we learn here is that when the
Cree initially created the Inhumans they
had done this for the purpose of having
the Inhumans operate as spies more or
less or possibly operatives and part of
their own army the way that this would
work is when the Kree first created the
Inhumans they gave them dormant genes
and these dormant genes were identical
to the genes of other races that the
Kree was looking to conquer because
before a member of the Inhumans
undergoes exposure to the Terrigen mists
for the most part they all look human
but once they come out they change
drastically and run in the run of the
accuser review is that the purpose of
this was that the Kree were going to
expose various members of the Inhumans
to the Terrigen mists and once they
undertook the particular form that they
were going to take they would in turn
infiltrate that race and begin to sort
of wreak havoc from within make that
race weaker and allow the Kree to invade
and take over now after this we see that
the Inhumans take a step away they are
no longer kind of like a main scene in
Marvel Comics and instead what we see
are the Inhumans appearing in major
story arcs and in major storylines but
despite the fact that they are appearing
in other comic books not as main stars
they still play major roles especially
when we get into a discussion about the
realm of kings and the war of kings
so the powers of Inhumans really kind of
vary for the most part they all have the
same base abilities I would go as far as
to say that all of the Inhumans at a
base level are equal to if not stronger
than Captain America I think that would
be a good way to kind of gauge their
physical prowess they are beyond
anything that an ordinary human is
capable of in addition we know that when
a member of the Inhumans undergoes the
process of terrigenesis or being exposed
to the Terrigen mists that more often
than not it expands their abilities now
it doesn't necessarily
mean that it will every single time
there have been instances where
individuals have undergone terrigenesis
and they have actually been weaker than
they were before
but the abilities in a person develops
when they undergo terrigenesis is not
always guaranteed we don't really know
what it is that they're going to become
in addition you have individuals like
Black Bolt and Black Bolt was really
kind of an extreme case I would go as
far as to some eyes the Black Bolt is
almost like a mutant among his own
people the powers that he developed as a
result of exposure to the Terrigen mists
are far beyond anything that any of the
Inhumans have ever developed what we see
is that he is able to manipulate
electrons for a multitude of different
effects when he was an infant he was
able to manipulate electrons and create
things out of thin air as an adult he's
able to manipulate electrons for
concussive blasts he's able to enhance
his physical strength and durability
reaction time speed by using the tuning
fork on his head to channel the the
electrons and his physical powers in
such a way that they can benefit him
however it is it he sees fit but of all
the abilities that Black Bolt has his
most formidable power is his voice and
this is what makes Black Bolt so iconic
and so ironic and Marvel Comics because
when you look at some of the greatest
leaders of our time their greatest
attribute has been their ability to
speak and in fact some people have been
able to speak in such a way that people
can't help but listen to them they can't
help but be pulled in to what it is that
they're saying but with Black Bolt it's
not like this because Black Bolt never
talks Medusa is usually always the one
who interprets for him in addition
members of the royal family who have
been around him for so long
are really kind of used to the way that
he expresses how he feels and so even
without him speaking they can usually
interpret what it is that he thinks
accurately enough to the very least
carry out his orders now the effects of
his voice in terms of the power and the
damage that he can do has been altered
over the years it's been expanded on
over the years when he first appeared at
the minimum at a whisper he was able to
shake boats or to create waves if he
screamed it was equivalent to an atomic
blast however in recent years
the power has been expanded on and so a
whisper is enough to destroy a large
chunk of of area several city blocks for
example and a scream is powerful enough
to destroy a planet so with a character
like him being as powerful as he is it's
really no wonder why he is the leader of
the Inhumans in addition to being one of
the more popular characters in the
Marvel Universe so I'm curious to see
how the Inhumans are going to be
depicted in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe we know for a fact that the
Scarlet Witch and Quicksilver are not
going to be Inhumans
but that does not mean that they are not
going to develop abilities from the
Terrigen mists so with the the Inhumans
it's really kind of interesting to see
how it's going to play out I mean do we
know if they're going to have a major
role in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
are they going to have their own film
and in turn be a major part of events
later on down the road or are they going
to be limited for example the Inhumans
and Black Bolt appeared in the House of
M although it was only for a couple
pages we see that apocalypse is a ally
of Magneto and has traveled to Wakanda I
believe to either convert Black Panther
to the side of Magneto or else to
destroy him we see the Black Bolt
appears as an ally of Black Panther and
destroys of hawk a--let's by whispering
and that's really about it he meets with
a couple other people in the panels but
there's really nothing more to the
Inhumans in the House of M storyline
than that however and the follow-up to
the son of M we see that they are a
major figure in that storyline we see
that in the events of the silent war
that the Inhumans have waged war against
humanity we also see that in the war of
kings and the realm of kings they play
huge roles so it's really kind of
interesting to see how these characters
are going to be depicted in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe now we do know that
Marvel of course is toying with the idea
that Marvel wants to bring the Inhumans
into the fold but we know that the
Inhumans are not going to be a
replacement for mutants that is to say
that even though Marvel doesn't own the
rights to mutant and doesn't own any of
the x-men they are not going to say
Cyclops is in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and he developed his powers
because he's an inhuman
or something like that they're going to
be totally separate and they're going to
be represented as being completely
separate so I'm curious here
I wonder if Marvel is going to introduce
the Inhumans the same way they were
introduced in the comics that they are a
very old race they've been isolated from
the world for so long that no one's
known about them and they suddenly just
popped up due to a set of circumstances
outside of their control they were
looking for someone and by virtue of
looking for that individual and the
comics Madame Medusa they happen to be
exposed to the rest of humanity I don't
really know how all this is going to
play out but what I do think is that
Marvel including the Inhumans in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is a great
idea because the Inhumans I've always
felt we're a very underrated group in
Marvel Comics
despite the fact that they were never
wildly popular among the mainstream they
were always a great group to read about
and they were always a great group of
people to really kind of follow up on
and it was always very happy for me to
see individuals like the Inhumans up
here in storylines I was absolutely
floored when I saw that the Inhumans had
appeared in the House of M storyline and
I was anxious just as much as any other
comic book fan to get my hands on the
six issue limited series the son of M
after the events of the house of M came
to a close regardless of how it is at
Marvel chooses to include the Inhumans
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe I do
think that we're going to be able to get
a very rich in a very great expansion to
the storyline that goes on in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in addition to seeing
them play some very interesting roles
when that being said I'm going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace
because the original sinister six was
composed of course Doctor Octopus Kraven
the hunter vulture electro Sandman and
Mysterio but we really haven't seen any
of these characters yet and any of the
model multimedia universe the only real
exception of that is of course the Fox
films and that had